قالت ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
المكونه اساسا من قوات كرديه مدعومه
امريكيا انها اقتربت من مدينه الطبقه في
ريف الرقه الغربي كما اكدت هذه القوات وقف
القتال في محيط سد الفرات بغرض صيانته
وذلك بعد تحذيرات اطلقها تنظيم الدوله من
احتمال
[موسيقى]
انهياره اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا
ونناقش فيما وراءه ما مدى جديه التحذيرات
من مخاطر انهيار سد الفرات وما هي امكانيه
توظيفه في معارك السيطره على الرقه وما هي
دلاله اصرار واشنطن على دعم القوات
الكرديه في تقدمها باتجاه الرقه رغم
التعقيدات التي يخل ها وجودها في هذه
[موسيقى]
المناطق على بعد كيلومتر واحد من مدينه
الطبقه في ريف الرقه الغربي تقف قوات
سوريا ديمقراطيه المكونه من قوات كرديه
تدعمها واشنطن بعد ان قطعت حسب قولها طريق
الطبقه دمشق ضاربه بذلك طوق حصار اخر على
تنظيم الدوله هناك ومحرز تقدما جدي باتجاه
المعركه المنتظره في مدينه الرقه تقدم قد
تعوقه مؤقتا عمليه اصلاح في سد الفرات
بعدما اخفقت في وقفه دعوات انقره
والمعارضه السوريه المحتجين على رهان
امريكا على القوات الكرديه في معركه الرقه
نتابع تقرير ناصر ايت الطاهر ثم نفتح
النقاش مع
ضيوفنا الطبقه ثم الرقه هذا ما تمليه
الخطه فكيف يجري التنفيذ منذ شهور تتقدم
ما تعرف بعمليه غضب الفرات باتجاه المعقل
السوري الاهم لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
بدعم جوي وبري من التحالف الدولي تحاول ما
تسمى قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه عزل مدينه
الرقه عن ريفها تمهيدا للمعركه الكبرى
هناك وهنا في الطبقه تتحول عقده الاتصال
الجغرافي بين محافظات سوريه عده الى ممر
الزامي كما يبدو نحو ذاك المبتغى ففي
واحده من اهم مدن الشرق السوري تمكنت
القوات المؤلفه اساسا من وحدات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه من انتزاع السيطره على مطار
الطبقه العسكري
الاستراتيجي استراتيجي هو ايضا سد المدينه
المعروف بسد الفرات فبه تكتمل السيطره على
الطبقه ومن خلاله سياتى نقل المعارك لاحقا
الى الجزء الغربي من مدينه الرق
غير ان السيطره على اكبر السدود السوريه
دونها معوقات فرضت على الوحدات الكرديه
منطقه البطئ والحذر لعل من ذلك توقف سد
الفرات عن العمل نتيجه خروج محطته
الكهربائيه عن الخدمه مما يهدد بارتفاع
منسوب المياه فيه يقول تنظيم الدوله
المسيطر حتى الان على السد ان مخاطر كبيره
تحيق به جراء استهدافه بغارات التحالف
الدولي بقياده واشنطن القوات الكرديه تنفي
ذلك الاستهداف وترى ان المسلحين انما
تحصنوا داخل السد لعلمهم ان هيكله لن
يتعرض للقصف بيد ان وكاله محليه كرديه بثت
تسجيلا مصورا يظهر لحظه سقوط قذيفه
اطلقتها الوحدات الكرديه على سد الفرات سد
ثمه من يطمئن بانه متين البنيان وفيه
اليات لتصريف المياه تلقائيا اذا تعرض لاي
هزه مع ذلك فلا احد كما يبدو يستخف بخطوره
الموقف فقد اوقفت القوات الكرديه وحلفاؤها
مؤقتا العمليات العسكريه في محيط السد
للسماح بتنفيذ ما قالت انها اعمال الصيانه
اللازمه ربما يستغل تنظيم الدوله الامر
لاستجماع قواه كما ينبه البعض في الطرف
الاخر غير ان كلا الطرفين يدرك ان انهيار
السد الذي يحتجز نحو 14 مليار متر مكعب من
المياه سيعني كارثه محققه ان ستغمر المياه
حينها ثلث مساحه سوريا ومناطق واسعه من
العراق التوفيق بين تلافي ذاك السيناريو
المرعب والمضي في خطه اطباق الخناق على
تنظيم الدوله هو ما يشغل
هؤلاء موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه اليوم مع
ضيوفنا من اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي السوري
محمد العبد الله ومن اسطنبول ايضا الدكتور
برهان كور اوغلو استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
في جامعه بهجه شهير ومن واشنطن ينضم الينا
دوجلس اليفنت كبير الباحثين في قضايا
الامن القومي في مؤسسه امريكا الجديده
والمستشار السابق للرئيس اوباما لشؤون
الامن القومي نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا وابدا
معك في اسطنبول محمد العبد الله حسب
متابعتك ل الوضع في سد الفرات ما حجم
الاضرار التي لحقت بسد الفرات وما هو مصدر
تلك
الاضرار اولا مساء الخير لك استاذه خديجه
وساده
المشاهدين يعني لحقت اضرار لكنها يعني
توصف بالبسيط يعني انشاء عمليه انشاء السد
وال من الجانب الهندسي اخذت في عين
الاعتبار هذا حس حسب رايي فنيين ومهندسين
جميع الاحتمالات احتمالات الحرب احتمالات
الزلازل الا ان يعني جسم السد تعرض ل
لاضرار بسيطه نتيجه بعض القذائف التي سقطت
عليه ويرجح انها من طرف قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه الا ان يعني يعني هذا هذه
الضوضاء او هذا التصعيد حول السد ما اراه
الا عمليه استثمار سياسي من كلا الطرفين
من طرف تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه ومن
طرف قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه فسد الى الان
في امان وسيبقى عمليا في امان حتى لو
تعرض لقص هذا اليوم ما تراجعت عنه قوات
سور الديمقراطيه و واكدت بان السد هو بخير
و سمحت لفنيين بالدخول عبر مناطقها
لمعالجه الخلل او لمعالجه بعد التصدع في
جسم السد وهذا يؤكد مره اخرى بان يعني
عمليه التهويل بمعنى ادق التي اثيرت حول
اسد ما هي الا عمليه استثمار
سياسي
لتخويف الناس ومن كلا الطرفين يعني تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه استثمر في هذا الموضوع
وقوا س الايه ايضا استثمر هذا الموضو ن
دوجلاس اليفنت يعني كيف يعني تقرا هذا
التصعيد من طرف قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
هذا الت حول سد الفرات المهم جدا بالنسبه
للناس في تلك
المناطق حسنا ك انت تسالين عن التصعيد من
قبل الاكراد وكما تعلمون الوت المتحده
وال الحلفاء لديهم اولويه اولك كبيره خاصه
في المرحله القادمه من الصراع وهذه
المرحله تركز بالدرجه على تحرير الرقه من
تنظيم الدوله وكان هناك عمل ما بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاكراد
لسنوات كثيره واعتقد ان هذه الامور لن
تتغير الان على الارض القوات الكرديه
وبقيه الحلفاء ماضون في عملهم سيد اغلو هل
هذا التبرير كاف لاستهداف السد
سيد دغلو هل تسمعنا دكتور برهان
كورلو ضيفنا في
اسطنبول هل التبرير الذي قدمه دوجلاس
اليفنت كافن لتبرير استهداف
السد لا طبعا طبعا يعني طبعا تركيا اصلا
بالاساس تعترض
على تعاون الامريكي مع ال وال بيكاكا ولا
نميز
بين هذين المنظمتين فلذلك اي تبرير لا
يمكن ان يعني يعني يبرر هذه الحركه يعني
طبعا بالنسبه لتركيا الخط احمر انه
التعاون مع بيادا هي لا تختلف عن داعش في
الاساس ل كلاهما منظمتين ارهابيين فلذلك
تركيا اصلا ترفض اشراك بياده وهذه القوات
ما يسمى بالقوات
ال السوريه
الديمقراطيه فلذلك ا يعني اعتراضنا قائم
فاي حركه من من من يعني ان تسمح لهذه
القوات ان يسيطر على المواقف هذا ليس ل
لصالح الشعب السوري في تلك المنطقه فلذلك
بالنسبه لتركيا طبعا ال كل ما يجري هي فقط
محاوله محاوله تبرير ل يعني لدعم هذه
المنظمه وطبعا كذلك لل للهجوم على رقه
ولكن اصلا الشعب السوري في تلك المنطقه
يعني يعاني من من هذه المنظمه مثل ما
يعاني من اصلا من داعش فلذلك ان نحن لا
نرى اي مبرر للسيطره على المطار للسيطره
على السد ويعني قد يكون هذه الهجمات
الضربات الامريكيه تهدد المنطقه ومستقبل
المنطقه مع البياده طيب محمد عبد الله ما
طبيعه وشكل هذا التوظيف السياسي الذي
تحدثت عنه قبل قليل ب احداث هذا التصعيد
حول سد الفرات من طرف قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه يعني هو محاوله استثمار
محاوله استثمار ويعني ابراز هذه المنظمه
كما سماها
الزميل برهان هو محاوله استثمار وتجييرها
لمصلحه بانها حريصه على سد الفرات وتخشى
من ان يقوم تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه بتدمير
السد وهذه مساله غير ممكنه لان هذا فعل
بالمطلق غير مسؤول لانه يعني يجب ان ي
الذي يتخذ مثل هكذا قرار بتدمير السد يجب
ان يكون وصل الى الى الى درجه الجنون وهذا
امر انا استبعده بالمطلق لانه حقيقه ستحدث
كارثه انسانيه لا مثيل لها ولا اعتقد بان
احد ممكن ان يغامر ويتخذ هذا القرار المهم
في القضيه هو استثمار سياسي قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه
واتحاد الاتحاد الديمقراطي يحاول ثمر
ويقدم يعني و ويقدم تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه على انه يعني كتله من الشر
المطلق انا هنا لا ادافع عن عن عن عن
التنظيم وبالتالي هو حريص على سد الفرات
وحريص على وقف
هذه الكارثه الانسانيه لاحظي معي اليوم
مثلا المتحدثه باسم قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه عادت وتراجعت بانه لا خطوره
على السد وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه سمحت
للفنيين والمهندسين بالدخول لاصلاح بعض
الاضرار التي التي وقعت وقعت على السد هذا
يذكرني ق منذ سه الصوره واضحه تماما وهي
تبرز سقوط قذيفه اطلقتها قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه على السد على سد
الفرات نعم نعم سقطت قذيفه وسقط قذيفه
ومصدر القذيفه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
والس تضرر ولكن اضرار خفيفه لا يمكن ان
تؤدي هذه القذيفه الى انهيار السد يعني
فنيا السد لا يمكن ان ينهار نتيجه قذيفه
او نتيجه قذيفتين او حتى اذا اردت نتيجه
غارات السد يعني فنيا منشا لمقاومه زلازل
بدرجه سته سته على على على سلم مرخت السد
ايضا يعني اخذوا في الاعتبار في الجانب
الفني ال الحروب وممكن ان يتعرض له سد
سقوط السد او انهيار السد ليس بالمسالك
البسيطه ولهذا السبب اقول بان يعني كانت
هناك يعني يعني يعني هذه الضوضاء حول هذا
الموضوع ما هي الا عمليه استثمار سياسي
سنتحدث بعد الفاصل عن اسباب اصرار واشنطن
على دعم الاكراد في تقدمهم نحو الرقه رغم
الحساسيات التي يثيرها وجودهم في هذه
المناطق ولكن بعد فاصل قصير فلا تذهبوا
[موسيقى]
بعيدا
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم مجددا الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش سيطره القوات الكرديه على مطار
الطبقه وتحذيرات تنظيم الدوله من انهيار
سد الفرات نرحب بضيوفنا من جديد واتحول
الى اوليفنت دوجلاس اوليفنت في واشنطن
يعني نريد ان نفهم سبب اصرار واشنطن على
دعم القوات
الكرديه وهي تعلم ان هناك حساسيات عرقيه
وشديده يعني وشكوك ايضا حول مطامع كرديه
يثيرها وجود هذه القوات الكرديه في
المنطقه واشنطن مدركه تماما لهذا الامر
استخدام اكراد هو شيء يثير القلق نعلم
ان دول الخليج ليست سعيده بتوجه
وايضا الكثير من الجهات الاخرى استهداف
مدن عربيه ض تركيا
ايير سعيده بتواجد الاكراد في المنطقه
ولكن بنهايه المطاف هناك دعم مستمر
للاكراد ان سياسه اخرى مجديه غائبه في
الوقت الراهن لذلك هناك استمرار في دعم
الاكراد لتحرير هذه المناطق التي تقع تحت
سيطره تنظيم الدوله لان ليس هناك اي بدائل
واقعيه لذلك الولايات المتحده ستنظر في اي
بدائل اخرى اذا ما توفرت بكل طيب هناك
بدائل تتجاهلها
واشنطن نحن نسمع هذا باستمرار عندما ياتي
احدهم ويطرح علينا بدائل فهذا يبقى فقط
كلام وليس هناك بدائل حقيقيه
واقعيه يعني هذا ليس كلام هناك وقائع على
الارض تقول ان الجيش الحر اخرج تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه من اماكن عديده واثبت
نجاعته في ذلك ربما اخر هذه المناطق منطقه
الباب بدعم تركي لماذا اذا يتم تجاهلهم
والاصرار على دعم الاكراد
فقط نحن ندعم بعض المجموعات من الجيش الحر
كما تعلمون هناك من يقاتل الى جانب
الاكراد ولكن هناك مجموعه من
المجمو المجموعات الاخرى داخل هذا الجيش
تنحى نواحي اخرى والنظام لا يساعد في
محاربه تنظيم الدوله سيد اغل الى اي مدى
يقلق ذلك
تركيا
يعني
اولا ما يتحدثون عن البديل اصلا موجود
وبالنسبه ل اعتماد اليادا وال بيكاكا اصلا
هؤلاء لا حتى لا يمثل الاكراد هم يعني
يعني يخرجون العرب والاكراد والتركمان من
من اماكنهم ويسيطرون على هذه الاماكن بحجه
محاربه داعش هذا كلام فارغ لا يحاربون
الداعش يحاولون ان يؤسسوا
كيان موالي للكاكا والبياده وحتى هم
يحاربون في حين الحاجه يحاربون القوات
الكرديه الاخرى في داخل الاراضي العراقيه
وبالنسبه لتركيا منذ منذ اكثر من ثلاث
اربع سنوات يؤكدون لامريكا ان لا يمكن دعم
اي منظمه ارهابيه بحجه محاربه داعش في
النهايه كلاهما محاربه منظمتان ارهابيه
ولكن اداره امريكا لا تسمع ذلك لا اوباما
ولا ترامب حاليا اداره ترامب يقولون انهم
ل لم لم يبداوا تاسيس سياستهم الجديد ولكن
يدعمون بكل قواهم بال هليكوبتر
بالمدرعات الاسلحه وحتى بجنود
امريكيين
للاكراد ولكن ان كلنا نفهم ان هناك خطه
اخرى تاسيس كيان جديد في المنطقه
للاستمرار بعدم الاستقرار في سوريا وهذا
شيء واضح جدا لا يمكن لا يم يكون هناك اي
تبرير لذلك تركيا قال ان الجيش الحر اثبت
جدارته في الساحه ولكن لم يدعم هذا الجيش
من قبل امريكا ولكن استمروا بدعم كل
الوسائل للبياده وال بيكاكا وهو معروف
انهم يعني يمثلون جز لا يتجزا من هذه
المنظمه الكرديه الارهابيه في المنطقه
فبالنسبه لل مبتش وقفوا امام الجيش الحر
اللي السيطره على ذلك وكذلك رقه تركيا
تقول يمكن تركيا تساهم ويمكن قوات سوريه
اخرى يساهمون لتحرير رقه ولكن الولايات
المتحده تريد للبياده تفتح تفتح تفتح مجال
للبياده حتى يكون هناك كيان اي في
المستقبل نحن لا لا لا لا نعتقد ان هناك
نوايا امريكيه سيئه سيقومون بما قاموا به
في في العراق تاسيس كيانات ح حتى لا يمكن
نتحدث عن مستقبل سوري موحد الان اي دا
يقول انه يمكن ان يضمن
اي هذه المناطق على المناطق ال الكرديه
ولكن هذه المناطق ليست كرديه فيها كثير من
العشائ العربيه ماذا نعم وسؤال ل محمد عبد
الله يعني الان يعني اذا سلمنا بهذه
الفرضيه التي تحدث بها الان
سيد دكتور برهان كور اوغلو ويقول ان الهدف
هو تاسيس كيان جديد كردي ليستقر
في سوريا يعني ما هي الاشكالات التي
يطرحها وجود هذا الكيان الجديد او بقاء
هذه القوات الكرديه في المنطقه بعد تحرير
الرقه
كبيره جدا كبيره جدا الاشكالات التي يعني
ستنتج عن عن عن عن قيام كيان كردي حسب
رؤيه البياد او حسب رؤيه بالضبط حسب رؤيه
البيك كي لانه يعني مفيد التذكير بان
البيادي او البيكا كي لا يمثلون الاكراد
لا بل ان يعني لدي معلومات مؤكده في
المناطق التي يسيطرون عليها هناك يعني
عمليا يعني يعني عدم رضا عن ممارساتهم
السياسيه على الارض لكن لسؤال يعني ماذا
ماذا تريد امريكا من دعم البيكا كي واضح
اصبح واضحا الان بما لا يدع اي مجال للشك
بان لامريكا لها خطتها ولها رؤيتها في
سوريا تركيا قدمت اكثر من خطه ل لتحرير
الرقه الجيش الحر بالمناسبه ليس في في في
في جرابلس و والباب حقق انتصارات مهمه جدا
على تنظيم الدوله لنذهب الى القلمون
الشرقي قبل تقريبا حوالي اسبوع الجيش الحر
ايضا طرد داعش من تلك المنطقه في في في
الجات بمحافظه درعا ايضا قوات الجيش الحر
حققت انتصارات
مبهره على على تنظيم الدوله اذا من خلال
دعم البياد لدى امريكا خطه اصبحت الى حد
ما معالمها واضحه حينما ترسل قواتها الى
قواتها الى منبج وترفع العلم التركي فيما
كانت تحضر يعني فيما كان الاتفاق بين
تركيا بين انقره وواشنطن على خروج اي قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه من منبج نرى ان الاصرار
الامريكي على بقائها ودعمها وامدادها لا
بل ان يعني يعني الان اصبحت القوات
الامريكيه على الارض سواء في منبج او في
تقريبا على كامل الشريط الحدودي بين تركيا
و وسوريا واضح ان هناك نوايا امريكيه على
ما ي تهدف
لدعمه نعم نحولها الى دوجلاس اوليفنت
باختصار واشنطن لماذا لا تعبر او لا تعير
اهتماما ابدا
لمخاوف المعارضه السوريه ولا
لانقره التي تصنف هذه القوات على انها
قوات
ارهابيه انا اتفاجا بما اسمع انا لا اتفق
مع ما قاله زميلنا من تركيا الولايات
المتحده الامريكا توافق بان البيدي قريبه
من البيكي كي ان لم نقل انها مساويه للبيك
كي نعلم ان هناك بالتاكيد
بعض الممارسات المرفوضه ضد السكان هناك في
في سوريا نحن لا نغفل هذه الامور اذا انا
لا اتفق مع المتحدث من تركيا نعم نعم هذه
واحده من
السياسات واحده من السياسات السيئه ولكن
لدينا مجموعه من المشاكل في المنطقه وكما
قلت سلفا ليس هناك بديل في الوقت الراهن
دكتور برهان كورلو باختصار في نهايه هذهه
الحلقه كيف تقرا تركيا
اذا يعني بقاء هذه القوات بعد تحرير الرقه
اذا اذا كان هذا هو السيناريو المطروح كما
تفضلتم انت ومحمد عبد الله
اصلا انا ارى انه هذا بقاء هذه
القوات المواليه للكاكا والبيدا غير ممكن
لانه المنطقه لا يتكون من عناصر كرديه حتى
العناصر الكرديه جزء كبير منها لا لا يوفق
هذه المنظمه هذا التطهير على يد الاسلحه
الامريكيه سيسيء لسياسه امريكا سيضر سياسه
امريكا الامريكا هناك اعتقد فريق من
العسكريين الى الان مقتنعين ان البياده
يفيدهم ولكن استعانه بمنظمه ارهابيه اخرى
هذه المنظمه الارهابيه سيتحول الى داعش
جديد والان كل اصلا اعمال التي قام بها
لداعش من تضح من قتل و الاف الناس قتلوا
وهجروا الى الحدود التركيه الى مناطق اخرى
كلها يدل على ان هذه المنظمه لا يختلف من
من داعش ولكن امريكا لا يفهم ذلك اعتقد
لاداره ترامب عندهم بعض الشكوك ولكن الى
الان لي لم يقتنعوا تركيا قدمت ادله كثيره
على على اللا المتحده ولكن اعتقد ان الرقه
سيكون هناك هزيمه اخرى لهذه المنظمه شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور برهان كوروغلو استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه بهجه شهير شكرا
لك ونشكر ايضا من اسطنبول محمد العب ع
الله الكاتب الصحفي السوري ونشكر ضيفنا من
واشنطن دوجلاس افنت كبير الباحثين في
قضايا الامن القومي في مؤسسه امريكا
الجديده اطيب المنى والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء